All right. Hey there. Welcome to
Answering Adventism, where we are
raising the general consciousness of the
Christian church as it pertains to the
cultic nature of Seventh Day Adventism,
equipping as many Christians as possible
to reach as many Seventh Day Adventists
as possible. So, thank you for being
here, especially if this is your first
time with us, Adventist or otherwise.
Hope you are doing well wherever you may
be at. It is great to be back with you
all once again as we embark on a uh
multi-part endeavor over the next few
weeks where I will hopefully help
connect some dots for you all regarding
what Seventh Day Adventists teach
regarding uh the priesthood of Jesus,
the kingdom of God, the atonement, and a
number of other issues that touch upon
the same subject. In part one, we're
going to be specifically looking at
Daniel chapter 7 as well as some
portions, large portions of Hebrews
chapter 9. I always like to preface when
it's going to be a rich and lengthy
presentation.
And tonight is one of those cases. So,
get comfortable. You might want to
consider taking some notes. It might at
some points feel like drinking from a
fire hose, but that's just the nature of
it. These are subjects that if you are
really going to want to engage with an
Adventist and cut through the
theological fog and confusion, you have
to understand the specifics, especially
with what we are going to look at
tonight. Because if you don't, it can
seem very convincing and you have to
know where it goes off the rails.
To help us out, we're going to be
listening to one of uh 10 presentations
from SDA Pastor Steven Boore in a series
he titled The Great Cosmic Controversy:
How God Clears His Name of All Charges.
Now, if you have been writing with us
for a little bit, this is going to ring
a bell, as it is something I'm
constantly harping on. You have to
remember that in this organization's
worldview, which is completely unique
and distinct to them, the Adventist God
clearing his name and vindicating
himself from accusations made by Satan
is the central fulcrum. It all centers
around this idea that Satan made
accusations in heaven prior to the
creation of the earth that the law of
God cannot be kept. It's unfair and
needed to be changed. This was triggered
by jealousy from Jesus being exalted to
be made equal with God the Father and
taken into special councils that Lucifer
was barred from. It is this fountain
head belief that then informs all of
their theology, more specifically why
the Adventist Jesus incarnated, what he
came to do, what he is currently doing
in heaven, etc. Yet none of it is
biblical.
The extra-biblical worldview is brought
to the biblical text to then read the
Bible in light of that, letting the
great controversy worldview do all of
the interpreting. This movement is not
big on exeetical rigor. Walking through
the text verse by verse to draw out the
author's intended meaning to then make
valid application. It is a lot of what
we call hopscotch exesus. various proof
texts from all over the Bible strung
together that are then used to bolster
the claims of the great controversy
worldview which isn't coming from the
Bible. And Steven Bor's presentation
will be a perfect example for you to see
this. But of course before we get into
it, a couple of housekeeping things.
I want to remind you that YouTube is not
our only outlet but one tool in the tool
belt. I want to remind you that you can
visit answeringadventism.com to access
all of our content, including videos and
written articles, our wall of memes, and
numerous other resources. Please,
please, please use the website if you
have questions. We get a lot of emails,
and it has gotten very hard due to time
constraints to respond to everyone in
detail, and that's often necessary.
oftentimes people ask questions that it
just takes a lot of time to sit down and
and write all that out. So that's why we
have numerous articles. You can browse
by topic over here on the side. You can
use this powerful search bar up top. You
can type in a topic. Let's just say um
Sabbath.
And boom, you're going to get 10
results. But you can also click the
little search and it will bring up
everything on the subject for you. You
can use that for names. You can use it
for all sorts of topics. Again, like I
said, you can come to the sidebar, boom,
and it'll break it down topically for
you. So, please, please, please utilize
this. Lots of the questions we get have
an article on the website which contains
hyperlinks to all of the primary sources
as well as scriptural reference for you
to compare, study, and equip yourself.
And like I said, the search bar up top
is a very powerful tool. Last month, our
website had over half a million page
views. Half a million page views. So,
thank you to those of you who have been
using it. Other people on Google who
have come across it that may not know
about the YouTube channel. The website
is really gaining some momentum
regarding indexing on Google. So, praise
God for that. The SDA church in the
coming years, folks, is going to have
its hands full because our website is
highly, highly optimized. You can also
donate through the website if you feel
called to do so and all donations made
through the website are taxdeductible as
we are a legally recognized 501c3
nonprofit.
On top of that, I also want to remind
you guys that you can join our
membersonly section here on YouTube and
gain access to our library of
membersonly content as well as our
membersonly Q&As's where I take your
questions. We engage as a community and
it is a great way to guarantee to get
your question answered if you haven't
gotten an email back. That's why I carve
out time to do that and we can try and
kill as many birds as possible with one
stone that way. To become a member,
simply click the little join button down
below this video. You can use the link
in the description box as well or visit
our channel homepage like you see on
screen where you will see the same join
button in numerous places. I want to
give a big thank you to all of our
members and partners who make this
effort possible. It really is the
generosity of both that enables us to
fulfill our mission to reach as many 7th
Day Adventists as possible with the
truth and it's working. We receive
testimonies every week from all over the
world. All over the world crazy all
walks of life in various situations who
by the grace of God have come to a
knowledge of the truth. And for that,
I'm super grateful because that's what
it's ultimately about. That is what it's
ultimately about. And you guys empower
that to happen. Whether you pray,
whether you watch, you engage, you
share, you donate, you partner, whatever
it may be, it is a team effort. Building
this uh community, equipping each other,
edifying one another um and taking that
out to the real world to keep uh or
reach rather real people and further
Christ's kingdom. That's what it's
ultimately about. So, thank you. With
that said, we have lots and lots and
lots to look at. So, let's dive in.
I'd like to invite you to turn in your
Bibles with me to the book of Daniel,
chapter 7. And we're going to read
verses 9 and 10, and then we'll jump
down to verses 13 and 14. Uh we've read
these verses before but now we are going
to summarize a few things that we've
mentioned before and move on to new
territory.
Now Daniel chapter 7 has a certain
sequence of events. We have the lion
that represents Babylon. We have the
bear represents Meo Persia. The leopard
symbolizes Greece. The dragon beast is
the Roman Empire. Then the dragon beast
sprouts 10 horns, which is the division
of the Roman Empire. And then you have a
little horn that rules for 1,260
years that end in the year 1798.
And then we have the following event
immediately mentioned after the little
horn uh horn's first period of rule
comes to an end. Daniel 7:es 9 and 10. I
watched till thrones were put in place
and the ancient of days was seated. Who
is the ancient of days? God the father.
And where does God the father live? Our
father which art in heaven we praise. So
it says the ancient of days was seated.
His garment was white as snow and the
hair of his head was like pure wool. His
throne was a fiery flame. Its wheels a
burning fire. A fiery stream issued and
came forth from before him. A thousand
thousands ministered to him. 10,000
times 10,000 stood before him. And now
notice the court was seated and the
books were opened.
So after which date does the judgment
begin? It has to begin sometime after
what date? After 1798. And we've
specified that it began when? October
22nd,
1844.
Now, this is not the end of the story
because it says the court was seated and
the books were opened. But then there's
another person that is going to join the
ancient of days in the throne room in
the most holy place. Let's go down to
verse 13.
I was watching in the night visions and
behold one like the son of man. Who is
that? That's Jesus Christ. One like the
son of man coming with the clouds. What
are the clouds? The angels coming with
the clouds of heaven. He came to where?
To the ancient of days. Is this the
second coming of Jesus? It can't be the
second coming because Jesus here comes
on the clouds but not to the earth. He
comes to where? To the ancient of days
in the most holy place. So it says here
he came to the ancient of days and they
that is the angels brought him near
before him. Now why did Jesus go in
there? What was the purpose of Jesus
going into the place where the court was
seated and the books were opened. Verse
14 tells us why he went into the
presence of the father. Verse 14 reads
then to him to whom? To Jesus. Very
well. Then to him was given dominion and
glory and what and a kingdom. So what
did Jesus go there for? He went there to
receive what? The kingdom. So it says
then to him was given dominion and glory
and a kingdom that all peoples, nations,
and languages should serve him. His
dominion is an everlasting dominion
which shall not pass away and his
kingdom the one which shall not be
destroyed.
All right.
So Steven Boore here is simply in line
with standard classical SDA teaching
regarding this paricopy. But no,
Mr. horror.
He even said this one of the times that
he said the statement, "Jesus coming on
the clouds is not Jesus coming with
angels."
You're right. It isn't referring to the
second coming. It is referring to the
ascension of Christ. Not 1844
and Jesus going to get a kingdom in
1844.
This is describing the son of man
ascending into heaven on the clouds and
approaching the father at his ascension.
to present himself in his once perfect
sacrifice before the father. You even
see a picture of this in the Levitical
priesthood work and the altar of
incense.
The altar of incense reminded the
Israelites that they were to pray and it
assured them that their prayers were a
pleasing aroma to the Lord but not
inherently so. Exodus 30 verse 10 tells
us that atonement had to be made for the
altar once a year. Like all the other
temple work, this pointed to the perfect
sacrifice of Jesus Christ which did
exactly that. He then ascended on the
clouds like the clouds of the incense
going up
and was accepted before the father on
our behalf. The concept of coming on the
clouds, coming on the clouds is a
central picture and theme throughout all
of scripture to refer to Yahweh as an
identifying mark of the almighty God. So
let's look at some of these. We could be
here all night on this topic. First,
Psalm 104. Notice
the psalter says, "The Lord wraps
himself in light as with a garment. He
stretches out the heavens like a tent
and lays the beams of his upper chambers
on their waters. He makes the clouds his
chariot and rides on the wings of the
wind. He makes winds his messengers,
flames of fire his servants.
So the psalter here declaring the
wonders of God
says that he wraps himself in light like
a garment using poetic language here
stretching forth the heavens as the
creator and he makes the clouds his
chariot.
Yahweh is the cloudriter. This is a very
regular motif all throughout the Old
Testament. Again, Isaiah 19
concerning God coming in judgment on
Egypt, an oracle concerning Egypt.
Behold, the Lord is riding on a swift
cloud
and comes to Egypt, and the idols of
Egypt will tremble at his presence, and
the heart of the Egyptians will melt
within them. So in this case, Isaiah
uses this terminology to refer to God
coming in judgment on Egypt.
This motif is seen all throughout both
Old and New Testaments and is
fundamentally representative of
something the Almighty does. The false
gods of the pagan nations were not the
ones that stretched out the heavens like
a tent. They aren't the cloudriter, the
one possessing all authority to judge um
as the ultimate authority over the
creation. We see this again in the New
Testament in Matthew 24 where Jesus
speaking to a Jewish audience told them
that they would see him coming on the
clouds. an audience that was familiar
with the Old Testament all throughout
the New Testament. Folks, when you hear
people say Jesus never claimed to be God
from people like Muslims, etc., it just
shows you don't understand the Old
Testament. He's he's calling himself God
constantly. He's forgiven sins. He's
healing diseases. He's doing all these
things all the Old Testament says Yahweh
alone does all these identifying marks
of of Yahweh. Jesus comes, it's like in
Mark chapter 2, there's like five times
just back to back. He's just bang bang
bang. They knew what he was talking
about because they knew the Old
Testament. That audience knew when he
said he was coming on the clouds, the
cloud writer, that's Yahweh.
That was Jesus again, once again
equating himself with Yahweh. The Jewish
audience very familiar with the Old
Testament would have been keenly attuned
to that language and concept just like
they were when he forgave people of
their sins, uh, etc. In Acts 19 uh 1:9,
not 19, 1:9, Luke writes that after
Jesus's final words to the disciples,
they were looking on. He was lifted up.
And what took him out of their sight?
A cloud.
In Exodus 13:14, the Almighty is said to
have gone ahead of Israel in what?
A pillar of cloud during the day and
then a pillar of fire by night. In
Exodus 16:10, Aaron speaks to the
Israelite community who turns to the
wilderness and God appears in what?
A cloud. In Exodus 19, the Almighty
tells Moses he's going to come to him in
a dense cloud so that the people will
hear when he speaks. In Exodus 40, Moses
writes that a cloud covered the tent of
meeting, the earthly tabernacle, and the
glory of the Lord filled the temple. And
because of this, Moses was unable to
enter that tent. In Psalm 68, the
psalter again exclaiming the wonders of
God says to sing praises to his uh to
his name and exalt him who rides on the
clouds. His name is Yahweh and rejoice
before him
over and over and over again. The same
thing is associated with identifying
Yahweh. The point being in Daniel 7 when
we see Jesus as the cloud rider, that's
what's going on there. The clouds don't
represent angels. It is Yahweh in the
flesh approaching the ancient of days at
his ascension to sit down on his throne
after accomplishing his redemptive work
to rule and reign as a priest king and
mediate forever for his people as all of
his enemies are made a foottool. This
will eventually lead to the consummation
of all things. no more sin, the curse
being lifted off the creation, the
saints inheriting the earth in fullness,
all the wicked being thrown out, the
resurrection and glorification of the
body, and so on. But the SDA church
cannot have this. They can't have Jesus
entering into the presence of God before
1844 in the same way, him ruling and
reigning presently because they tie, as
you heard, the investigative judgment to
this passage.
But no, kings rule over a kingdom.
The ascension was Jesus's inauguration
as a king, not a high priest. We've
talked about this, I don't know how many
times. Their fundamental belief on the
investigative judgment says Christ was
inaugurated as a priest at his
ascension. No, he was not. And we're
going to see more of this later. That
was his inauguration as a king where he
took his throne, but kings rule over
kingdoms. And what does Daniel 7:13-14
tell us?
He read it that when the son of man, the
cloudriter, came on the clouds at the
ascension, he approached the father and
was given dominion and glory and a
kingdom that all peoples, nations, and
languages should serve him. His dominion
is an everlasting dominion which shall
not pass away, and his kingdom one that
shall not be destroyed. All of that is a
present reality, and it was a present
reality long before 1844.
The gospel is how Jesus's kingdom
spreads. It goes to all tribes, tongues,
peoples, and nations, changes people's
hearts, which in turn changes the
nations because nations are made up of
people. This parallels revelation
perfectly. Christ's dominion is an
everlasting dominion, never going to
pass away, and his kingdom never
destroyed.
Jesus said at the ascension right before
giving the great commission the taking
of the gospel to all tribes, tongues,
peoples and nations that all authority
in heaven and on earth has been given to
him
will be given to him in 1811 years. No,
he said all authority in heaven on earth
is already his. So go therefore
because he has all authority. The church
can then boldly go out trusting that he
will conquer all of his enemies,
all principalities, all rulers, all
authorities, death, sin, all of it
that's in the world, will be conquered.
He will rule and reign forever, etc.
All of this did not become a reality in
1844. And Daniel 7 has nothing to do
with the investigative judgment. In
October 22nd, 1844, the SDA pioneers
read into the fact that it says the
books were opened and judgment began and
assume that this means Jesus is now
opening the books of individuals,
that angels are documenting for each
individual person all the way back to
Adam who has professed faith to see who
is and isn't really a true believer. and
that Daniel was shown this process
beginning
which would mean Christ being given all
authority, dominion and power began when
the investigative judgment began.
Now Boore is going to get into what
Christ's kingdom is in their system. Pay
very close attention here. Now the
question is what is Christ's kingdom?
We've touched on this point before.
Usually we think of a kingdom in
territorial terms, don't we? the
territory or the geographical area over
which an individual rules. But when it
comes to Jesus, his kingdom is composed
of the people that belong to his
kingdom. In other words, his kingdom are
his people. So what did Jesus go to do
before the father? He went to perform a
work of judgment to decide who is truly
a member of his kingdom. Are you
following me or not? And after the last
person who has professed Jesus Christ as
savior has been judged, the kingdom of
Jesus is what? The kingdom of Jesus is
complete. So in other words, the
judgment process reveals who was a true
follower of Jesus and who wasn't. And as
soon as all cases have been decided,
then the kingdom of Jesus is made up.
That's what Jesus went before the father
to receive. to receive the kingdom to
determine who are the subjects of his
kingdom.
All right.
So his next point,
Christ's kingdom will be complete after
the completion of the investigative
judgment where it is shown who is and
isn't a part of his kingdom.
Catch that. That's their claim. Christ's
kingdom is only made up of the people.
He said most people think of of a
kingdom as being uh territorial.
So he places a dichotomy between
Christ's kingdom being territorial and
personal. We've seen this before. We
looked at this with Dennis Prieb. They
love to make these sort of false
dilemmas
or uh false false uh you know binaries
that it's an eitheror when no it's a
both and.
Christ is ruling over both peoples and
geographic regions.
Stephen, Jesus has all authority in
heaven and on earth. That's domain
geographic territory, sir. And then
commands his people to go therefore
discipling the people in the geographic
territory.
That's a both and. It's not mutually
exclusive.
It makes you wonder, folks, if they if
if the Adventist church really
understands why the apostles were hated.
The apostles were not hated, folks, just
because they said, "We believe in Jesus.
We're Christians." That's not all that
it was. Modern day has has really lost a
lot of the significance of what was
going on, especially in the book of
Acts, why they were hated.
It was fine in the pagan Roman Empire to
say, "I believe in Jesus." Well, that's
fine. But you also have to recognize
these other, you know, the Roman system,
the governmental system. You have to bow
down to the system.
That's more than people.
They were hated because they said,
"Well, no, we're not doing that because
not just you, but this all all of
creation is the Lord Jesus's. He
purchased it with his own blood, and you
have to bow the knee to him because he's
going to come back one day to judge the
living and the dead. So, repent and
believe the gospel. That's why they were
hated.
Yeah, I know that you believe Caesar is
Lord. No, no. Jesus is Lord and you're
going to need to bow the knee to him.
Yeah, Joe Biden, Xihinping,
Jeff Bezos, all all the money, you know,
powerful people, whatever it may be.
You're not as powerful as you think you
are. This is Jesus's domain. This is
Jesus's kingdom that you're in. And he's
going to come back one day to throw the
wicked out of his kingdom. So, bow the
knee. That's why they were hated.
Not this idea that just Jesus only rules
over people and it's not geographic
territory.
But furthermore, Daniel, just like
Isaiah and the psalter, spoke about
Jesus's kingdom going out to all nations
eventually leading to peace,
the nations putting their swords down
and then flowing up to the mountain of
the Lord. Notice what the Old Testament
tells you about the kingdom of God.
Folks, the Old Testament is rife with
prophecy about the kingdom. The Messiah
and his kingdom, not just the Messiah,
the Messiah and his kingdom. He would
come and usher in a kingdom. The Jews
missed the way that it would look. So
did the disciples.
And so do Jews today. They think it's
going to be this political overhaul here
o on earth as some sort of, you know,
Jesus coming and sitting in a a
political, you know, building here on on
earth.
No, he's ruling and reigning from
heaven. His throne is up in heaven, but
he's still ruling and reigning and his
kingdom did come. But notice what the
Old Testament has to say,
the infamous Isaiah 9 6-7.
So Isaiah prophesying about Messiah's
kingdom, which Jesus says in Luke had
come upon unbelieving Israel, like we
will see. But notice, for to us a child
is born, to us a son is given, and the
government shall be upon his shoulder.
And his name shall be called Wonderful
Counselor, Mighty God, Everlasting
Father, Prince of Peace, of the increase
of his government, and of peace. There
will be no end.
On the throne of David, and over his
kingdom, to establish it, and to uphold
it with justice and with righteousness.
From this time forth and forever more,
the zeal of the Lord of hosts will do
this.
Not he'll incarnate and then ascend and
then there'll be 1811 years. Then the
government will be upon his shoulders
and no
this is a prophecy about the incarnation
of Christ. Part of which includes that
he would come and the government would
be upon his shoulder and he'd be called
wonderful counselor, mighty God, and
what will be a hallmark of his
governance?
The increase of his government and peace
to which there'll be no end. The exact
same thing Daniel 7 says about Jesus's
rule and reign and dominion.
This increase has gradually been
happening for 2,000 years. And it's why
more than likely we have a lot of
history left. The fullness of the peace
that Christ's rule and reign will bring
is not here yet. And the church needs to
get busy in taking the gospel to the
world.
But Jesus possesses dominion over both
the people and the territory. Not just
the people. The earthly rulers and kings
have to submit to Jesus.
Again, that's what got the disciples in
trouble. Not just believing in Jesus,
but their belief paired with calling the
rulers and governing authorities to
repent and bow the knee to Jesus who is
ruling and reigning and has all
authority in heaven and on earth, even
over them and their supposed kingdoms
and their God-given office on earthly
government uh of of earthly government.
But I mentioned Luke.
Notice Luke 11:14-23.
An exchange that Jesus had with the
ruler uh uh religious rulers during his
ministry.
Now he was casting out a demon that was
mute.
When the demon had gone out, the mute
man spoke and the people marveled.
But some of them said,
"He cast out demons by Beelible, the
prince of demons." while others to test
him kept seeking from him a sign from
heaven.
But he knowing their thoughts said to
them, "Every kingdom divided against
itself is laid waste and a divided
household falls,
and if Satan also is divided against
himself, how will his kingdom stand?
For you say that I cast out demons by
beelible. And if I cast out demons by
beelible, by whom do your sons cast them
out,
therefore they will be your judges?
But if it is by the finger of God that I
cast out demons,
then the kingdom of God has come upon
you.
When a strong man fully armed guards his
own palace, his goods are safe. But when
one stronger than he attacks him and
overcomes him, he takes away his armor
in which he trusted and divides his
spoils. Whoever is not with me is
against me, and whoever does not gather
with me scatters.
So catch this. Jesus talking about using
parabolic language to some degree
talks about Satan's kingdom
and he was accused of casting out demons
by the power of the devil
but others sought to test him. Then Luke
says that Jesus knew what they were
thinking which like I mentioned earlier
the Old Testament says only God the
Almighty can do this. First Kings 8:39.
another evidence that Jesus was claiming
to be or is claimed to be God there.
Luke tells us, but because he knew their
thoughts, he tells them that he couldn't
be casting out demons by the power of
Satan because a kingdom divided against
itself cannot stand. The demon is on the
side of Satan, part of Satan's kingdom.
So, how and why would Satan cast out
Satan when they're a part of the same
kingdom of darkness? Then, what did
Jesus say in verse 20?
that if he casts out demons by the power
of God, then the kingdom of God
has come upon you, not will come, has
come.
And he gives an analogy there of
he gave the same analogy actually
multiple times throughout his ministry
about the thief coming in and trying to
plunder the goods.
but basically says that Jesus came and
essentially overthrew Christ's kingdom
then divided his spoils etc.
But Jesus was indeed casting out demons
by the power of God and not Satan which
means the kingdom of God had come upon
them. It's here.
This was the ushering in of it that was
foretold in the Old Testament that the
religious leaders missed something else
that was prophesied by Isaiah. They were
hardened to the truth. missed the
arrival of the Messiah in his kingdom,
which was a part of God's ultimate plan
to graft in the Gentiles, not just
ethnic Israelites. The point being,
Jesus's kingdom is here and now. It is
advancing and growing over both
territories and people, gradually over
time like a mustard seed that is sewn
and it gradually increases in size to
eventually have entire colonies that
nest within its branches. That's the
analogy that Jesus gave. He said, "The
kingdom is like a little leaven in a
lump.
And it slowly rises and rises and rises
and rises and rises. And you may not
feel like you're seeing the increase of
it, but gradually over time it is
happening. And then eventually it's just
this massive conglomerate thing.
Nothing to do with Jesus going to
receive his kingdom after conducting an
investigation to see who does and
doesn't make up that kingdom which is
relegated to people and not both people
and geographic territories.
the increase of peace will be gradual as
more and more of Christ's enemies are
made his foottool and the last enemy to
be defeated will be death which we will
look at momentarily but he said that
Daniel 7 speaking about Jesus going
before the father to begin the
investigative judgment to determine who
is and isn't a part of his kingdom he is
reiterating what Ellen White said notice
this is allegedly inspired commentary
folks on Matthew 22 2,
Christ in his sanctuary, page 157.
Quote, in the parable of Matthew 22, the
same figure of the marriage is
introduced, and the investigative
judgment is clearly represented
as taking place before the marriage.
Previous to the wedding, the king comes
in to see the guests, to see if all are
attired in the wedding garment, the
spotless robe of character washed and
made white in the blood of the lamb.
Matthew 22:11 and Revelation 7:14.
Supposedly,
he who is found wanting is cast out, but
all who upon examination are seen to
have the wedding garment on are accepted
of God and accounted worthy of a share
in his kingdom and a seat upon his
throne. This work of examination of
character, of determining who are
prepared for the kingdom of God, is that
of the investigative judgment, the
closing work in the sanctuary above.
Close quote.
So, the parable of the wedding feast is
supposed to be about the investigative
judgment, even though it comes from
having a great controversy worldview.
Something that no one until Ellen White
was supposedly revealed.
No one had a great controversy worldview
until they came along. That's what it's
about. That That's what it's about. That
that that you can totally use the
historical grammatical method of
interpretation to arrive at this
conclusion. Remember Ted Wilson says,
"We all the only approved hermeneutic in
the SDA church is the historical
grammatical method of interpretation."
Right? That's what the original audience
would have understood the the the
parable of the wedding feast to be
about. Investigative judgment starting
in 1844, October 22nd in uh America by a
bunch of fringe anti-trinitarian
heretics that believed in a false god, a
false gospel, a false prophet, and
started a false church. Yeah. But in
this system, Jesus's ascension wasn't
about him being inaugurated as a king.
It was about him being inaugurated as a
high priest. And we will look at this
error again. I want to I just want to
reiterate that you have to understand
this.
The investigative judgment is about
determining who is and isn't prepared
for the kingdom. Never mind that Paul
tells us in Colossians 1 that those who
have been regenerated have already
presently been transferred from the
kingdom of darkness and brought into the
kingdom of light. That was happening
before 1844.
No, the Adventist Jesus isn't ruling and
reigning over his his kingdom yet, his
kingdom, because he's not real. That
will come when he ceases functioning as
a high priest, something we will look at
in part two, and he takes off his
priestly garments and puts on his kingly
garments, something we have looked at
before, speaking of Ted Wilson, the last
time we looked at it was when he
actually cited from that portion of
Ellen White's vision. It was at his
annual council address from last year.
You know, SDAs were coming at my throat
when I I brought that up initially. And
then through divine providence, a couple
weeks after that, the annual council
happens and Ted Wilson literally
references it and says the exact same
thing that I said and like, "No, no, no.
You don't know what you're talking
about. You're a liar." Yeah. Okay.
C-arter. C-arter.
They can cry and whine all they want.
They know. I know and they know. I know.
And they know that I know. This is
supposedly what Daniel was shown from
God. Though
that's what Daniel 7 is supposed to be.
He didn't know the date, but the
Adventists do. And it was Daniel being
shown that on October 22nd, 1844 AD,
Jesus would enter into a most holy place
apartment of a building in heaven to
begin a judgment of only those who have
professed faith in him to see who is and
isn't fit for the kingdom, aka who isn't
uh who is and isn't keeping the law
perfectly, vindicating God's character,
silencing Satan, etc.
Are you seeing, Christian, how all of
this stuff is connected like a
theological web?
how you can't do this grabag alocakart
style adventism that the modern you know
neoadventist wings of the movement will
try and pitch to you
the foundational error of 1844 begets
more error it is like a domino effect
and I respect Steven Boore and those
like him because this man is not stupid
this man is not ignorant again he's not
one of these modernist SDAs that tries
to do their own customized you know
build an adventism
where I just go through and oh I take
this and oh I like this and oh I grab
this and anytime you you question that
well that's not my adventism. Yeah.
Yeah. No. Steven Boore is not one of
those. But according to those types
Steven Boore is a hyperconervative
lunatic fringe whatever. No.
It's like when they throw slurs at me.
It doesn't change the facts. This man
knows the system and all of its
connectedness which is why he doesn't
beat around the bush and play word
games. And for that, I respect him
because this guy is teaching this stuff
like we're seeing in this video
constantly. I mean, this guy's doing
sometimes 36 presentation serieses. Is
that a word? Serieses. You get my point.
But Mr. Boore, unfortunately, this
fictional worldview clouds your reading
of the text, no pun intended, which
causes you to import all sorts of
concepts into the text that are not
there.
Now, there are many ways to refute this.
Let's look at some more, three more that
are internal problems for the SDA
framework. Understand this folks. You
have to understand when you're
critiquing Adventism, you have to be
able to explain to an Adventist, "No,
no, I'm doing an internal critique.
I'm showing internal inconsistencies for
your problem." Don't try and say, "Well,
that's cuz you believe this and you
that's irrelevant." No, this is
irrelevant to my own beliefs. I could be
a Buddhist. It doesn't matter. These are
internal critiques, not an external
critique. So here is the first.
Hebrews 9:24-8.
For Christ has entered not into holy
places made with hands which are copies
of the true things, but into heaven
itself.
Now to appear in the presence of God on
our behalf. This is a key phrase there
which we're going to look at. Nor was it
to offer himself repeatedly as the high
priest enters the holy places every year
with blood not his own. For then he
would have had to have suffered
repeatedly since the foundation of the
world. But as it is, he has appeared
once for all at the end of the ages to
put away sin by the sacrifice of
himself.
And just as it is appointed for man to
die once, and after that comes judgment,
so Christ, having been offered once to
bear the sins of many, will appear a
second time, not to deal with sin, but
to save those who are eagerly waiting
for him.
So the SDA church claims that what was
on earth was an identical scale model
copy of what is in heaven. They will
cite Hebrews 81 1-5 typically Hebrews
8:5 to try and support that that what
was on earth is a copy of what is in
heaven. Let's grant them that that's
what the text is saying. Okay. God's
presence was only ever manifest where in
the earthly sanctuary
most holy place.
So unless Hebrews was written after
1844,
the author just destroyed this
interpretation of of Daniel 7 because
Daniel was shown Jesus approaching the
father in heaven. The author of Hebrews
tells us that Jesus entered into the
presence of God not to offer himself
repeatedly like the Levitical priest had
repetitive sacrifices, but he appeared
there once for all time at the end of
the ages to what?
put sin away by the sacrifice of
himself.
Notice what John Owen says in his
massive exposition of the book of
Hebrews, which is on the shelf behind me
right there. Seven books, largest work
on the book of Hebrews, the largest
exposition work on the book of Hebrews.
Regardless of your opinion of the
Puritans and John Owen, argue his ex
Jesus, not his tradition and being a
Puritan or a Protestant, whatever.
I always want to make sure that
potential new listeners know I cite a
lot of sources to extinguish the idea
that this is answering Adventism's
private interpretation or belief.
Adventists are going to tell you that's
his opinion. You're just citing him. You
just believe that cuz he believes it.
No, that's not why we're citing people.
Believe it or not, people out there are
smarter than you.
And study up on the Puritans and what
you had to do in order to get your
masters of divinity as a Puritan. You
didn't just have to know Greek. You had
to be able to debate in Greek.
John Owen's work on the book of Hebrews
is not only the most extensive ex Jesus
of the entire book, again, seven
volumes, thousands of pages, but his
ability to handle Greek is at an elite
level. Commenting on verse 24 and the
phrase, he entered into the presence of
God on our behalf. Notice what he
highlights as it pertains to why this is
so important contextually.
meaning what is the author getting at?
Why is he saying these things? Why does
he say the stuff in the order he says it
in? Why does he compare and contrast the
priest going in repetitively and leaving
and going back in and leaving and going
back in to Christ putting sin away,
sitting down versus standing, etc. Why
is he connecting all these things
together?
We have a lot to look at here, but it's
very rich and it needs to be grasped
because if you get this, you're going to
see why the SDA church's claim is so
opposite of scripture and be able to
engage with SDAs at a level that you
need to if you're going to meaningfully
interact and not have a bunch of straw
men. Notice
his exposition on on 9:24.
A further degree of opposition between
our high priest and those of the law,
the Levites, is expressed in these
words. So remember, the theme of Hebrews
is a compare and contrast between what
makes Jesus better than the old. He's a
better priest, a better Moses, a better
Joshua, better than the angels, etc.
They, the Levitical priests, entered
into the holy place to appear for the
people and to present their
supplications unto God.
But this was only in an earthly
tabernacle, and that before a material
ark and mercy seat.
In what is uh in what is here ascribed
unto Christ, there are many differences
from what was so done by them. So now
he's going to list some of those. One,
in the time of what he did, or doth,
then there's the Greek. Now the word now
at this present season and always
what those others did was of no
continuence.
Catch that. But this now
Jesus's is expressive of the whole
season and duration of time from the
entrance of Christ into heaven unto the
consummation of all things.
So he declares it in the next verse. He
never departs out of the sanctuary to
prepare for a new sacrifice as they did
of old.
There is no amount of time wherein it
may not be said, he now appearth for us.
Close quote.
So, do you catch why in verse 28 the
author said that Christ isn't returning
to deal with sin?
That's what the Levitical priest did.
Jesus isn't returning to deal with sin,
but to save his people.
Owen points out how part of what makes
Jesus's priesthood superior and better
is that he entered into God's presence
one single time and didn't have to leave
like the Levites to continue making
sacrifices and then reenter into the
most holy place the following year.
Catch that.
When Christ exit exits out, it's to
return for his people because sin has
already been put away at the cross.
Verse 26, but Owen continues
two in the end of his entrance into this
heavenly sanctuary. There's the Greek,
that is to appear.
Absolutely. His entrance into heaven had
other ends, but this is the only end of
his entering into heaven as God's
temple.
The seat of the throne of grace, as our
high priest,
and the whole discharge of the remaining
duties of his sasserodal office are
comprised of this word, as we shall
immediately demonstrate.
Three, in that he doth thus appear,
there's the Greek,
that is the immediate presence of God.
So the Greek for what's translated in
what we read, the presence of God in
opposition until the typical symbols of
it in the tabernacle before which the
high priest presented himself. The high
priest appeared before the ark, the
cherubam and mercy seat composed into
the form
of a throne.
The form of a throne.
But Christ enters into the real presence
of God, standing in his sight before his
face. And this expresseth his full
assurance of his success in his
undertaking and his full discharge from
that charge of the guilt of sin which he
underwent.
Had he not made an end of it sin
had he not absolutely been freed from
it, he could not have thus appeared with
confidence and boldness in the presence
of God. Woo! Wee!
Owen is cooking."
Notice the layout of the earthly
tabernacle was in the form of a throne.
But the Levites didn't actually have
one. They were not kings.
They never sat down because the work of
dealing with sin was always ongoing.
Which is why the author in Hebrews says,
"The earthly priests were always
standing at their office daily."
But unlike them, Christ did put sin away
at the cross. Verse 26, because like
scripture tells us, our sins were placed
on him. He who knew no sin was made sin
so that we might become the
righteousness of God. He bore our sins
in his body on the cross. And the author
of Hebrews, his point is that had Christ
not put sin away there, he couldn't have
entered into the presence of God having
our sins still placed on him.
The putting away of it wasn't a
transference to heaven. It was a dealing
with it, an actual removal, experation,
the scapegoat. That was the function of
the scapegoat. We'll look at that in
part two.
It's why the believer themselves can
have confidence to enter into the
presence of God as well. The SDA church
wants to tell us that Jesus transferred
sin into a heavenly sanctuary building
in heaven
where it's in the actual face-to-face
presence of God somehow and Jesus on the
cross only paid the penalty for sin. But
Owen continues pointing out uh further
the compare and contrast
the words being opened that nature of
the thing itself namely of the present
appearance of Christ in heaven must be
further inquired into and it may be
declared in the ensuing observations.
One, it is an act of sacraidal office.
Not only he who is our high priest doth
so appear, but he do so doth as the high
priest under the law, whereby it was
typified and represented.
His entrance into the holy place, the
presentation of himself before the mercy
seat was in the discharge of his office,
and he did it by virtue thereof.
And this is one principal foundation of
the church's comfort, namely that the
present appearance of Christ in the
presence of God is a part of his office,
a duty in the discharge of it. Two, it
is such an act and duty of our high
priest as supposedth the offering of
himself as a sac or a sacrifice for sin
antecedently, meaning at a previous
time.
there unto for it was with the blood of
the expedatory sacrifices offered before
the altar that the high priest entered
into the holy place. It hath therefore
regarded until his antecedent sacrifice
or his offering himself in his death and
bloodshedding unto God.
Without a supposition hereof, he could
not as our high priest have entered into
the sanctuary and have appeared in the
presence of God. Wherefore three, it
supposeth the accomplishment of the work
of redemption of the church.
His words in this appearance before God
are expressed. John 14:4, I have
glorified thee on the earth. I have
finished the work which thou gavest me
to do, and now I come unto thee.
He was sent of God into the world on
this great Aaron. for this great work.
And he returned not unto him. He
appeared not in the presence of him that
sent him until he had fulfilled it and
was ready in all things to give an
account of it unto the eternal glory of
God. Close quote.
Wow.
So on top of what we read before, Owen
rightly points out that Jesus came to
accomplish the work of redemption, the
new creation, and he did so in full
because that's what scripture says he
was sent to do. And he would not return
back into heaven, until that work was
accomplished. Not just paying the
penalty for sin, which is death, which
is what the Adventist Church teaches,
but then the work's going to continue in
a second phase of atonement, the
investigative judgment, to continue
dealing with sin by transferring it to
heaven. No. Jesus accomplished
redemption in full, put sin away, and
entered into the presence of God, having
completed in full the work of
redemption. He continues,
"For
in this his presence he presents himself
unto God as a lamb that has been slain."
Revelation 5:6. He is not alive or yeah,
he is not alive and lives or now I
should say now. He is now alive and
lives forever. But there must as unto
efficacy in this appearance be a
representation of his sacrifice, his
suffering, his death, his blood, of
himself as a lamb slain and offered unto
God. And this was to be so in answer
unto the blood of the expedatory
sacrifice which the high priest carried
into the holy place.
For he was himself both the priest and
the sacrifice,
the offerer and the lamb.
And as that blood was sprinkled before
the ark and the mercy seat to apply the
atonement made unto all the sacred
pledges of God's presence and goodwill.
So from this representation of the
offering of Christ of himself as a lamb
that had been slain. In this his
appearance before God doth all the
application of its benefits unto the
church proceed.
Wow.
So catch that. This is very very vital.
Just like the Levitical priests had to
present a sacrifice before God, so
Christ did the same, but he himself was
both the sacrifice and the offerer of
the sacrifice.
I've talked about this a lot before.
Was Jesus inaugurated to be a priest at
his ascension? No.
He was inaugurated as a king at his
ascension. ascended, approached the
Father, presented his perfect
accomplished work, sat down on his
throne to begin the rule and reign that
knows no ends after accomplishing the
work of the redemption of all things
which he was sent to do. His priesthood
was inaugurated at his baptism where the
true anointing of oil was poured out on
him, the Holy Spirit, and the better
blessing spoken over him by his father
from heaven.
The high priest had to offer up the
sacrifice on the day of atonement.
Jesus was both the high priest and the
sacrifice. Offering him up at Calvary.
He prayed his high priestly prayer in
John 17 as a high priest.
The Adventist church wants to say, well,
the sacrifice took place at Calvary, but
then the work of the day of atonement
antypically will begin in 1844 and have
this large chasm and divide. No, no, no.
There are numerous problems with the
idea that Jesus began his priesthood at
his ascension. And it proves once again
Ellen White contradicts the Bible
constantly because that's where the SDA
church is getting this from ultimately.
Furthermore, just like the earthly
priests entered into the presence of God
to present the sacrifice offered on
behalf of the people to apply the
benefits of that, so Christ entered into
the true presence of God face to face
and presented the offering of himself as
both the priest and the sacrifice
himself being the lamb that had been
slain to apply the benefits of his
sacrifice to his people, the church.
The SDA church teaches that Jesus began
the investigative judgment to see who is
and isn't worthy of Christ's benefits
because that's what Ellen White claimed.
We've looked at this before. Great
controversy. 1888 edition, page 479.
Quote, "Attended by heavenly angels,
there's those clouds.
Our great high priest enters the Holy of
Holies and there appears in the presence
of God to engage in the last acts of his
ministration in behalf of man to perform
the work of investigative judgment and
to make an atonement for all who are
shown to be entitled to its benefits.
Ah
so there you see part of why Boore said
coming on the clouds in Daniel 7 refers
to the angels. But this doesn't jive
with what the author of Hebrews is
paralleling in this chapter.
Jesus entered into the true presence of
God as the high priest and sacrifice to
present that sacrifice before God in
which the benefits of that sacrifice are
applied to the people, not to
investigate who is and isn't worthy. But
back to Hebrews 9, as Owen notes,
Revelation 56 parallels this same thing
as well as Daniel 7. They all center
around the ascension and what happened
there. It all fits like a glove. Nothing
to do with this crazy theory they have.
But something else of vital importance
to highlight is in verse 27. Hebrews
9:27
what the author says regarding dying
once and then comes judgment.
Notice,
and in like manner, as it is appointed
unto men once to die, but after this the
judgment, so also Christ was offered
once
to bear in himself the sins of many, and
unto them that look for him shall he
appear the second time without sin, unto
salvation.
The second part of this penal
constitution is judgment. After death,
the judgment,
it is not a particular judgment on every
individual person immediately on his
death, although such a judgment there
be, for in and by death there is a
declaration made concerning the eternal
condition of the deceased. But judgment
here is opposed unto the second
appearance of Christ unto the salvation
of believers which is the great and
general judgment of all at the last day.
Then he includes the Greek there and
says this is used with respect unto this
day or taken absolutely do signify a
condemnatory sentence only.
And then the Greek again, the
resurrection of or unto judgment is
opposed unto the resurrection of or unto
life. John 5:29.
So it is here used judgment. That is
condemnation for sin follows after death
in the righteous constitution of God by
the sentence of the law. And as Christ
by his death doth not take away death
absolutely, but only as it is penal, so
on his second appearance, he doth not
take away judgment absolutely, but only
as it is a condemnatory sentence with
respect unto believers.
For as we all must die, so we must all
appear before his judgment seat. Romans
14:10.
But as he hath promised that those that
believe in him shall not see death, for
they are passed from death unto life,
they shall not undergo it as it is
penal, so also he hath that or yeah, so
also he hath that they shall not come
into judgment. John 5:24. They shall be
freed from the condemnatory sentence of
the law.
Close quote.
This flies in the face of what Steven
Boore and the SDA church tell us
regarding their sanctuary theory because
Christ not only accomplished redemption
by putting sin away at the cross, not
transferring it to a building in heaven,
but Owen also points out that the Greek
grammar conveys that this work has freed
believers from judgment for
condemnation.
Rightly recognizing that the same thing
is said by Jesus himself in John 5.
We've looked at this, I don't know how
many times, and what have I always
pointed out? Jesus says that believers
do not come into judgment or
condemnation.
Not zero judgment at all.
Now, a lot of people will point there
and say, "Christians won't come into any
jud." Well, then you create
contradictions. That's not what's being
said in John 5:24
because Jesus is talking about judgment
for condemnation there.
We will all stand before God on the
final day and give an account. But for
the believer, this will not be for
condemnation because we've already
passed from death to life.
Did you catch that in Hebrews? And why
the author says this in verses 27 and 28
after saying Jesus accomplished
redemption in full?
What that also means is that the
believer was already judged in Christ at
the cross and like Christ who died and
raised again. So that was the believer
passing from death to life.
And it's why when Jesus returns the
second time, it's not for our
condemnation or dealing with sin, but
for the consummation of all things and
our physical uniting with him.
Yet the investigative judgment is
a judgment for condemnation. That's
literally what it is. And it's
exclusively for professing believers.
They'll try and claim it's simply a
separation of the wheat from the tears.
But the fact is it is a judgment for
condemnation that every single
professing believer enters into. And
some will make it, some won't. It
includes those who make it, who aren't
condemned. But it is a judgment for
condemnation despite this.
But Jesus and the author of Hebrews say
that's already taken place for the
believer. It happened in the person of
Christ for us who accomplished our
redemption. And this was long before
1844.
So those are a number of reasons why
this is false. Sin is not still being
dealt with by Jesus in a second phase of
atonement where sin is transferred in
type into a building in heaven for him
to start his second phase of atonement
ministry in 1844. I could keep drilling
in on this same paricopy, but I still
have a lot to get to. But just note that
the idea that Jesus approached God the
Father in some new way in 1844 does not
work. Another issue is that in Ellen's
vision on this, she claims that the
father was on a throne in the holy place
and in 1844, he got up off that throne
with Jesus and they moved into the most
holy place and sat on another throne.
This again violates the SDA church's own
claim that what was on earth was
identical to what is in heaven to the
extent that it's a literal building like
what was on earth.
The earthly holy place did not have a
throne, nor was God's presence ever in
the holy place, only in the most holy.
And like John Owen pointed out regarding
Hebrews 9:24, the layout resembled a
throne, pointing to Christ's throne, but
they didn't actually have one. They were
not kings.
And another problem with what Boore
claimed, the author of Hebrews talks of
Christ's rule and reign as present as he
sits on his throne. This is because
MelkiseDC was a high priest and a king.
Hebrews 7:1.
Jesus being after the order of
MelkiseDC. Hebrews 6:1 19-20.
He is simultaneously both a priest and a
king. So, as you see in our logo, we
love Hebrews 6 19-20.
Notice what it says.
Well, we're going to look at 13-20.
Actually
look up at the look the leadup and
transition.
For when God made a promise to Abraham,
since he had no greater by whom to
swear, he swore by himself,
saying, "Surely I will bless you and
multiply you." And thus Abraham, having
patiently waited, obtained the promise.
For people swear by something greater
than themselves, and in all their
disputes in oath, is final for
confirmation.
So when God desired to show more
convincingly to the heirs the promise
the unchangeable character of his
purpose, he guaranteed it with an oath
so that by two unchangeable things in
which it is impossible for God to lie.
We who have fled for refuge might have
strong encouragement to hold fast to the
hope set before us. What is that hope?
We have this as a sure and steadfast
anchor of the soul. A hope that enters
in
the inner place behind the curtain
where Jesus has gone as a forerunner on
our behalf having become a high priest
forever after the order of Melkchisedc.
So after talking about Christ's
superiority over angels, Moses, Joshua,
etc., and explains how all the law and
the prophets pointed to Jesus, he then
transitions to God remembering his
promise to Abraham and how he is
faithful. He explains that the promise
God made to Abraham was sworn by an oath
with God himself swearing by himself
because there's nothing higher than
that. You can read Genesis 15. That's
essentially what the author is pulling
from. But then he ends with a
transitioning statement from this into
the priesthood of Jesus and why it's
superior by saying that we believers
have a sure and steadfast hope in anchor
for our souls. a hope that enters into
the inner place behind the curtain. A
place where Jesus has gone as a
forerunner ahead of us on our behalf,
having become a high priest forever
after the order of Melkchisedc.
So Jesus ascended and entered into the
heavenlies as a representative
forerunner for those that he died for to
mediate on their behalf. Now, the SDA
church by way of Ellen White claims that
the phrase here behind the curtain is
referring to the first veil that
separated the holy place from the
courtyard. They have to have this
otherwise nothing happened in 1844.
Notice what Ministry Mag magazine says
by way of Roy Gain
where he says what Ellen White says
about this and he cites her from an
article titled within the veil where did
Christ go.
Quote, Ellen White uses Hebrews 6:1
19-20 to refer to Christ's passage
through the first veil
and the consequent
commencement of his holy place ministry.
Catch that.
We're going to get to this point here in
a moment, but
the commencement of his holy place
ministry,
not most holy place ministry, his holy
place ministry. Just remember this. Now,
he cites Ellen White. The ministration
of the priests throughout the year in
the first apartment of the sanctuary
within the veil which formed the door
and separated the holy place from the
outer court represents the work of
ministration upon which Christ entered
at his ascension.
It was the work of the priest in the
daily ministration
to present before God the blood of the
sin offering also the incense which
ascended with the prayers of Israel. So
did Christ plead his blood before the
father in behalf of sinners and present
before him also with the precious
fragrance of his own righteousness the
prayers of penitent believers. Such was
the work of ministration in the first
apartment of the sanctuary in heaven.
Close quote.
So Roy Gain puts forth the idea that
what Ellen White saw was only symbolic,
not literal. He's one of the guys that
popularized this, which is what his
article basically tries to put forth.
There's not a literal second curtain up
there. This is just imagery pointing to
certain realities, which is fine because
that has no bearing on the point. She
very clearly says that at his ascension,
Christ only entered behind the first
veil
to do an analogous work of the Levitical
priests, but in a building in heaven to
plead his blood before the father on
behalf of penitent individuals.
The central claim being that Jesus is
still dealing with sin in heaven like
the Levitical priest did on earth. So
don't get bogged down in the weeds of a
literal curtain or not. They love to
argue these sorts of tertiary matter
matters that really have no no bearing
on the the point. They love stuff like
that. They love to well this over here
and and well no irrelevant to the point.
We know this is false because it says
the veil he entered behind was the inner
place and it was after the order of
MelkiseDC
who was a high priest.
Again, notice John Owen's exposition of
Hebrews 6:20.
In part, he says he is in his entrance
into heaven or the holy place.
Then he has the Greek there, a
forerunner.
This the high priest of old when he
entered once a year into the holy place
was not.
Catch that.
The earthly priest was not a forerunner
for us.
He entered therein to himself but he
made no way for any to follow after.
He did not go before the people to give
them entrance into the holy place. But
both by his entrance and his return
signified their exclusion forever.
We have then herein another instance of
the excellency of our high priest and
his office when he Jesus entered into
the holy place. He did it not merely for
himself but to go before to lead and
conduct the whole church into the same
glory.
as a forerunner, he is entered within
the veil, that is into heaven itself,
the place of the glorious presence of
God.
Close quote. The author isn't saying
that Jesus entered into a building in
heaven with compartments to do an
analogous work of dealing with sin like
the Levites. His point is that Jesus
entered into the presence of God which
on earth was typified by the most holy
place in the sanctuary building and that
Christ went in as a forerunner and
actually opened the way which we're
going to see in a little bit for all of
us which is what he goes on to say
something the Levitical priests did not
do.
He is setting the stage for the listener
who the original audience were Jewish
converts to Christianity
and he's setting the stage for the
listening audience to begin going on to
describe Jesus's priestly work which
we've looked at some in chapter 9.
We will also see some in part two where
we're going to look at almost all of
chapter 7. The point being when looking
at Hebrews in total as an entire
presentation, the idea that Jesus had
some functional change in ministry in
1844 completely misses the point. We're
supposed to believe that the author is
trying to tell us in Hebrews 6:19-20
that Jesus entered into a building in
heaven, but only the holy place
compartment to do a work parallel to the
Levites, but in heaven. And this is an
anchor for the soul.
What?
Not only does this not make sense in the
flow of the presentation, but the entire
theme of the book is about how Jesus is
better, not a parallel, only in a
different location, utilizing his own
single sacrifice to deal with sin like
they did,
and not continually repeat sacrifices,
etc.
That isn't the anchor for the soul.
That's a hope for the believer. The hope
for the believer's soul is that Jesus
accomplished redemption in full, was
completely accepted, entered in one time
into the presence of God, opening the
way for all believers to do the same,
and he rules and reigns with all
authority, mediates perfectly for his
church, forever lives to intercede for
them, and he's making all of his enemies
a foottool. Now, four years later, in
the same publication, Ministry magazine,
another SDA theologian, George Rice, he
disagreed with Roy Ga and Ellen White,
and said this
quote, Hebrews 6:13-20 deals with
dispensing the blessings of the
Abrahamic covenant to Abraham and his
children. It notes one that God swore by
himself to fulfill his promises. Two
that he interposed with an oath to
convince the heirs of the covenant that
he would fulfill his word and three that
by these two unchangeable things we have
strong encouragement to seize the hope
fulfillment of God's covenant promises
set before us and four that hope enters
within the veil where Jesus has gone on
our behalf as a priest after the order
of MelkiseDC.
The context does not deal with the
sanctuary per se. In other words, with
its apartments, furniture, services,
etc. It introduces the veil simply to
indicate where Jesus is ministering,
where the hope of the covenant people is
centered and from whence the covenant
blessings are dispensed. So, it would
seem that the word veil is used
metaphorically to point to the sanctuary
as a whole. and that unlike Hebrews 9:3,
Hebrews 6 makes no attempt to identify
to which veil it refers. Close quote. No
mention of Christ as the forerunner,
which is like the whole crux of the
matter there. Not just that, but it says
that Christ entered where only the high
priest could go. MelkiseDC was a high
priest. Where could only the high priest
go, folks? The presence of God.
But four years earlier, Roy Gain says
that Ellen White clearly identified and
used Hebrews 6:19 to refer to the first
veil separating the holy place from the
courtyard. However, it's not a literal
curtain. It's just symbolic.
But then George Rice claims the author
of Hebrews has no intentions of
identifying which veil it refers.
It's only symbolic, too. But at least he
recognizes that contextually the focus
is upon where Jesus is ministering,
which is heaven itself, not a
compartment in a building that he
transitioned around in in 1844.
And notice he says the context doesn't
deal with the sanctuary per se. Yet then
he claims the word veil is used
metaphorically to refer to the sanctuary
as a whole,
making no attempt to distinguish which
veil, which would mean he disagrees with
Ellen White. Either way, the author of
Hebrews is very evidently utilizing the
earthly sanctuary imagery to tell us
that Jesus entered into the true
presence of God, going behind the
curtain that only the high priest could
enter, which is a picture of the reality
that Christ entered into heaven and sat
down on his throne to rule and reign as
a priest king. Which is why his
ascension again was his inauguration as
a king and he took his throne, not his
inauguration as a high priest.
So that's about the fifth reason why
this theory is flawed. The final one
piggybacks off the claim that Jesus was
inaugurated to be a priest at his
ascension. Remember what Roy Gain said
in that article regarding the priestly
ministry of Christ. He cited Ellen White
who mentioned what Christ was allegedly
doing from the ascension until 1844.
This is a big one. You got to get this.
Let's hear her expound on this further
in the same book, but a different quote
than the one that Roy Gaines cited.
Great Controversy page 428. Quote,
in the service of the earthly sanctuary,
which as we have seen is a figure of the
service in the heavenly
when the high priest on the day of
atonement entered the most holy place,
the ministration in the first apartment
ceased.
God commanded, "There shall be no man in
the tabernacle of the congregation when
he goeth in to make an atonement in the
holy place until he comes out."
Leviticus 16:17. So when Christ entered
the Holy of Holies to perform the
closing work of the atonement, he ceased
his ministration in the first apartment.
But when the ministration in the first
apartment ended, the ministration in the
second apartment began.
When in the typical service, the high
priest left the holy of the day of
atonement, he went in before God to
present the blood of the sin offering in
behalf of all of Israel who truly
repented of their sins.
So Christ had only completed one part of
his work as our intercessor
to enter upon another portion of the
work and he still pleaded his blood
before the father in behalf of sinners.
Close quote. So she claims that from the
ascension until 1844,
Christ was only in the holy place of a
building in heaven. The type is supposed
to be the Levitical priests.
They worked daily in the outer apartment
daily the daily ministry
presenting blood.
So this is what they teach that Jesus
did. But no, yet again, this breaks down
for two reasons. Besides Hebrews
6:19-20, like we looked at, notice what
we're told in Hebrews 9,
which actually is what leads into what
we read in 9:24-8.
Hebrews 9 1-10.
Now even the first covenant had
regulations for worship in an earthly
place of holiness. For a tent was
prepared, the first section in which
were the lampstand and the table and the
bread of of presence. It is called the
holy place. Behind the second curtain
was a second section called the most
holy place, having the golden altar of
incense and the ark of the covenant
covered on all sides with gold in which
was a golden urn holding the mana and
Aaron's staff that budded and the ta and
the tablets of the covenant. Above it
were the cherubam of glory overshadowing
the mercy seat. Of these things we
cannot now speak in detail.
These preparations having thus been
made, the priests go regularly into the
first section, performing their ritual
duties.
But into the second only the high priest
goes,
and he but once a year, and not without
taking blood, which he offers for
himself and for the unintentional sins
of the people. Remember this.
By this the Holy Spirit indicates that
the way into the holy places is not yet
opened as long as the first section is
still standing
which is symbolic for the present age.
It's a scribal note. According to this
arrangement, gifts and sacrifices are
offered that cannot perfect the
conscience of the worshipper, but deal
only with food and drink and various
washings, regulations for the body
imposed until the time of reformation.
So he starts the chapter by
transitioning into describing the layout
of the earthly sanctuary. This is where
7th Adventists are going to point to to
try and say that Hebrews 6:19-20 is only
referring to the first veil because here
the author mentions that the earthly
sanctuary had two veils. But as we saw,
no, that is clearly referring to the
veil which shielded God's presence. You
don't read the Bible backwards,
especially considering uh in the same
chapter like we saw, he goes on to
explain that Jesus entered into the
presence of God one time and sat down.
That did not happen in 1844. But with
regards to Jesus being in the holy place
apartment for 1811 years until 1844
doing analogous work to the Levitical
priests only in heaven. Notice verse 8.
After explaining the work of the
Levites, we are told that only the high
priest had access to God and only once a
year.
On the day of atonement, he had to offer
a sacrifice for himself before he could
do the work for the people because he
himself was a sinner. Then we are told
that by this the Holy Spirit indicates
that the way into the holy places is not
yet opened while the first section is
still standing. And then you have the
scribal note in brackets of which is
symbolic for the present age. They add.
So while the Levitical priesthood work
was standing, the way into the presence
of God was shut off to people. That's
the point. The way into God's presence
was closed off while that work was going
on. Got it?
Now notice when he transitions in the
next chapter to explaining how Jesus is
better, what the comparison is.
Hebrews 10 11-22.
And every priest stands daily at his
service offering repeatedly the same
sacrifices.
So the daily work was a standing work
which can never take away sins. But what
did he say in 9:26? Jesus put sin away
at the cross. But when Christ had
offered for all time a single sacrifice
for sins, he sat down at the right hand
of God,
waiting from that time until his enemies
should be made a foottool for his feet.
For by a single offering, he has
perfected for all time those who are
being sanctified.
And the Holy Spirit also bears witness
to us. For after saying, "This is the
covenant that I will make with them
after those days, declares the Lord. I
will put my laws on their hearts and
write them on their minds." Then he
adds, "I will remember their sins and
their lawless deeds no more.
Where there is forgiveness of these,
there's no longer any offering for sin."
Therefore, brothers, since we have
confidence to enter the holy places by
the blood of Jesus, by the new and
living way
that he opened for us through the
curtain, that is through his flesh. And
since we have a great priest over the
house of God, let us draw near with a
true heart in full assurance of faith,
with our hearts sprinkled clean from an
evil conscience, and our bodies washed
with pure water.
Did you catch this?
The Levites in their daily work were
always standing because they had to make
continual sacrifices both in the daily
ministry and the once a year day of
atonement.
But in contrast to them, Jesus entered
one time into the presence of God after
his single sacrifice,
sat down on his throne, and is waiting
to return until all of his enemies
should be made his foottool. His single
sacrifice has perfected for all time
those who the spirit is now sanctifying.
Which is why there doesn't need to be
any sort of repetitious work of dealing
with sin. As the author says back in
9:26, he put sin away at the cross. And
when he returns, it's not to deal with
sin. But it's because of Christ's
perfect sacrifice and the fact that it
effectually perfects all of those for
whom Christ made it that God can
remember their sins no more. where there
is forgiveness,
there's no longer that sort of work
going on. Hence why the author cites
Jeremiah 31, which prophesied this. Not
that sins stand on record in a building
in heaven to still be dealt with during
the new covenant age, but that they are
remembered no more, remitted, gone.
And because all of that is the case,
that leads us up to verse 19. This is
the key. The author could then tell us
that because of Jesus, all believers
have access into the presence of God by
a new and living way, the blood of
Christ. And through Jesus himself, he is
the living way. His flesh is the true
curtain that the earthly sanctuary
pointed to the curtain in the sanctuary.
Jesus is the doorway into the presence
of God that all of us can enter through
into his presence just like the curtain.
But remember what did we read back in
chapter 9 in verse 8.
The author told us that while something
specific was going on, the way into the
presence of God was not open to
everyone. Only to the high priest once a
year. And what was it?
The daily ministry,
the first apartment work.
that while that daily work was still
happening, the way into God's presence
was closed off.
Catch that. But since believers can
enter into the presence of God with
boldness now, because a way has been
opened, that means the daily
ministration work of the first
apartment's not standing anymore.
It's not what Jesus was doing from his
ascension until 1844. It's over. The
daily work was a standing work of
dealing with sin, not a seated work of
accomplishment.
But it falls apart even more for their
position. We've looked at this numerous
times. The priest in the daily
administration did not
take blood into the sanctuary on a daily
basis for penitent individual
Israelites.
You have to catch this.
That's what they try to point to for
their type antitype typology.
Leviticus 4 says that outside of the day
of atonement, blood was only taken into
the holy place on two occasions.
When the priest sinned, when the entire
Israelite community sinned
unintentionally, not for penitent
individual Israelites.
And that alone refutes this theory
because that's supposed to be the
picture for individual penitents in the
new covenant
that individual penitent Israelites
would show up with their sacrifice, give
it to the priest, confess their sins,
laying their hands on the animal,
transferring in type their sin to the
animal. The animal would pay the
penalty. They would kill it. The
penitent Israelite would leave knowing
that their sin was taken care of. The
priest would then supposedly take the
blood, which in type transferred the sin
into the holy place to be sprinkled
before the veil to then rest there until
the day of atonement to then be cleansed
and dealt with. No, it's not what
happened.
The priest sacrificed the animal for the
individual penitent Israelite and it was
over. Blood was only transferred in on
two occasions. Go read Leviticus 4. This
all boils down to the SDA church not
understanding what the intercession of
Christ actually looks like and why his
simultaneous role of priest and king is
so important to grasp.
They don't even mention this in their
fundamental belief about the
investigative judgment. There's no
mention of Christ kingship because again
that he's going to take off his priestly
garments at a point in the future which
we're going to get to in part two where
Steven Boore talks about Christ ceasing
work as an intercessor in contradiction
to Hebrews 7. But these are only what
now nine reasons
eight reasons why this theory breaks
down and there are a lot more. But back
to Steven Boore. He also said once the
investigative judgment is complete,
Christ's kingdom will be complete. No,
Mr. Boore.
Once all of Jesus's enemies are made a
foottool,
death and Hades are cast into the lake
of fire, meaning death is the final
enemy. 1 Corinthians 15. And the
contents of Hades, the wicked, are cast
out of Christ's kingdom. That's when the
consummation of all things will take
place and Christ's kingdom will be in
its fullness.
But because he has relegated the kingdom
to only people
and not both people and territory, he's
not able to see this. But like I
mentioned, 1 Corinthians 15, notice what
Paul says. 1 Corinthians 15:22-28.
For as in Adam all die,
so also in Christ shall all be made
alive. Parallel to Romans 5 here. But
each in his own order. Christ the first
fruits. Then it is coming those who
belong to Christ. Then comes the end
when he delivers the kingdom of God uh
to God the father after destroying every
rule and every authority and power. For
he must reign until he has put all his
enemies under his feet. That didn't
start in 1844.
The last enemy to be destroyed is death.
For God has put all things in subjection
under his feet. But when it says all
things are put in subjection,
it is plain that he is accepted who put
all things in subjection under him.
Meaning Christ subjects himself to the
father functionally.
When all things are subjected to him,
then the son himself will also be
subjected to him who put all things in
subjection under him. that God may be
all in all
fits like a glove with the book of
Hebrews.
Paul is talking about the resurrection
in this chapter and he gives the famous
gospel presentation at the beginning and
then hinges that gospel to the
resurrection by saying if Christ did not
raise our faith is useless.
He then says that Christ is the first
fruits of the resurrection. A lot packed
in there. And then at his coming those
who belong to him will be raised. Then
he comes uh uh and then comes the end
when Jesus will deliver over the kingdom
to the father after Jesus has destroyed
every rule and every authority and
power.
That's not just people. And why is that?
because he must reign until all things
are put under his feet and made under uh
all his enemies are put in subjection
under his feet. Jesus is a king right
now.
This is what he's presently doing. And
the final enemy to be defeated is what?
Death.
And just like the author of Hebrews,
Paul then cites from Psalm 8, which is a
messianic psalm about Jesus, which says
that all Christ's enemies will be
brought under his feet and subjection.
After all of Christ's enemies are made a
foottool, he will then present his
kingdom to God the Father at the
consummation of all things.
Not after he's conducted an
investigation.
That's why Jesus hasn't returned yet.
Not because of the investigative
judgment or because enough Adventists
haven't been, you know, made sinlessly
perfect and they're vindicating God and
all the other theories that I've heard
Adventists put forth over the years.
Remember, Jesus already has all
authority in heaven and on earth. He's
already seated on his throne as his
enemies are being made a foottool.
And Daniel tells us that once this
begins,
that kingdom knows no ends. His dominion
will be forever. This did not begin in
1844.
Shoot. It hasn't even technically
started. It's just it's in process right
now. It'll really be him ruling and
reigning after the investigative
judgment. He puts on his kingly garments
and takes off the priestly garments. No,
this did not begin Adventist in 1844.
It's not about him investigating people
to vindicate God against Satan. Satan's
already a defeated foe. He is a pawn in
the hands of the Almighty.
God is not subject to the accusations of
a creature such that he's on trial and
has to clear his name. And it is truly
heartbreaking how the SDA system warps
such wonderful theology by infusing into
it all sorts of foreign concepts at the
behest of keeping a lie alive. I don't
know Steven Boore personally, but
there's just something about him that I
love. I know some I talked to a lot of
former a like I I never got into Boore.
There's just something about the guy. I
really like the guy. He's just like he
kind of has to me just kind of has like
a grandfatherly like fig. I don't know.
I just like the guy. He seems like a
very genuine and sincere guy from
listening to hundreds of hours of this
guy at this point.
He's on my personal list of SDAs that I
beg God to give eyes to
because he's not a he's not a stupid
man.
Sorry folks.
Lots of Adventists are going to b and
scoff at him as a fringe, you know,
hyperconservative.
Gosh,
when no, he he's he's actually a very
smart guy, and I really hope that God I
really hope that God saves him. I read a
statement from Great Controversy, page
428,
uh, where Ellen White describes this
judgment process and what happens when
every case has been decided. It's a
short statement but very meaningful.
When the work of investigation shall be
ended, that is when everybody who has
professed the name of Christ has been
evaluated in the judgment. When the work
of investigation shall be ended, when
the cases of those who
in all ages
have professed to be followers of
Christ, are you catching that? So, how
many people are judged? How many of
those? All. And who are the ones that
are judged? Not not only true believers,
but those who have what? professed to be
followers of Christ. So she says, "When
the work of investigation shall be
ended, when the cases of those who in
all ages have professed to be followers
of Christ have been examined and
decided, then and not till then,
probation will close and the door of
mercy will be shut." Are you with me?
Now when the door of mercy is shut,
that's the moment when the sentence is
pronounced
either for life or not for life.
When do those people who have been
judged favorably receive their reward?
They receive the reward when Jesus
comes. Is there a period of time between
when the sentence is given and when
those who are faithful to Jesus receive
the reward? Yes. In between those two
points, when probation closes and when
Jesus comes to reward his people by
taking them to heaven, there is what the
Bible calls the time of trouble. Now,
that would be the subject of study for
our next lecture, lecture number nine in
this series, but we're not going to deal
specifically with that now. But I want
you to catch the chronology. You have
the close of probation. Then later you
have the uh receiving of the reward and
in between you have the seven last
plagues and the tribulation or the time
of trouble.
Yes. And Stephen, we just looked at that
same page of great controversy, page
428, where Ellen White blundered the
daily administration of the Levitical
priests and taught that they daily took
blood into the sanctuary for individual
penitent Israelites. and they didn't.
Leviticus 4 is clear about when this did
and did not happen. And every time that
I ask Adventists about this, they cite
when it talks about the blood being
taken in for the the nation who sinned
unintentionally.
That's not the parallel that she's
making. She tries to make a parallel to
when the individual penitent Israelite
showed up. No, blood wasn't taken into
the holy place for that. But Christians
understand what he said about judgment
and what the claim of the investigative
judgment is. Now, he was not exhaustive,
but he highlighted a central aspect that
when the investigative judgment ends,
this is when the sentence is pronounced
for life or not for life.
And it is what is happening in in
between the point of the sentence being
given and the reward being received. The
reward received is determined in the
investigative judgment.
And remember it is a judgment only for
believers.
Got to catch that.
life or condemnation.
But first off, the reward given is not
salvation.
Because salvation isn't a reward, it's a
gift. We've looked at this numerous
times.
The ways in which Ellen White refers to
salvation as a reward over and against
scripture.
The rewards Jesus returns to give in
Revelation 22:12 are the rewards one
will receive for the labors in Christ's
kingdom. Because see, they don't
understand Christ's kingdom is already
here. And Christ said when he leaves and
comes back, he doesn't want you to bury
your stuff in the ground and sit there
and be twiddling your thumbs. You need
to get busy for the kingdom, Christian.
Don't be sitting there watching the
news. And I mean, I'm not saying don't
don't keep up on things and and have
hobbies and whatnot, but you need to be
doing things for the kingdom.
That's the reward that that
this is a whole subject in and of itself
that I don't have time to veer into, but
it's not the reward for either being
saved or being damned.
But the investigative judgment is
allegedly only for professed believers
and is essentially a sifting of the
wheat and the tears. They'll claim to
determine who is and isn't truly saved,
who is safe to save and silence Satan,
etc. Because all of this is ultimately
about the Adventist God having to
vindicate himself from Satan, like the
title of the presentation, the great
cosmic controversy,
how God clears his name.
This doesn't jive with Jesus's own
teaching when it comes to judgment for
condemnation in believers. Aside from
the obvious Romans 8:1, there's
therefore now no condemnation for those
who are in Christ Jesus. Those are who
are uh united to him. Not to be confused
with what the Adventist Church calls
abiding in Christ. Jesus also taught the
same thing in his ministry. We looked at
this in passing earlier with John Owen.
Notice
John 5 19-29. In this paricopy, we are
at a portion where Jesus has just healed
a blind man and it was done on the
Sabbath. The religious leaders take
umbrage with this as they always did and
sought to question him. The focus for
John is ultimately on Jesus's deity and
how things he says shows he claims to
have authority on par with the Almighty.
As the Old Testament makes very clear
the psalmistic claims in Psalm 103 2-3,
Jehovah heals all of one's diseases.
The religious leaders would have known
this. On top of that, he healed the man
on the Sabbath to which he's accused of
breaking it and demonstrates to them not
only his authority over such, but that
what he did was entirely lawful and
didn't actually violate the Sabbath,
claiming that he and his father have
been working since the creation. further
putting salt in their wound by driving
home the point that he is God Almighty.
But he doesn't stop there. On top of
this, he then says the following.
So Jesus said to them, "Truly, truly, I
say to you, the Son can do nothing of
his own accord, but only what he sees
the Father doing. For whatever the
Father does that the Son does likewise.
For the Father loves the Son and shows
him all that he himself is doing. And
greater works than these will he show
him, so that you may marvel.
For as the Father raises the dead and
gives them life, so also the Son gives
life to whom he will, equating himself
with God. For the Father judges no one,
but he's given all judgment to the Son,
again, equating himself with God. That
all may honor the Son just as they honor
the Father. Whoever does not honor the
Son does not honor the Father who sent
him. Truly, truly, I say to you, whoever
hears my word and believes him who sent
me has eternal life. He does not come
into judgment, but has passed from death
to life.
Whoops.
He continues, I forgot a slide here, but
he continues by saying, "Truly, truly, I
say to you, an hour is coming
and is now here, when the dead will hear
the voice of the Son of God, and those
who hear will live. For as the Father
has life in himself, so he has granted
the Son also to have life in himself.
and he has given him authority to
execute judgment because he is the son
of man. Do not marvel at this for an
hour is coming when all who are in the
tombs will hear his voice and come out.
Those who have done good to the
resurrection of life and those who have
done evil to the resurrection of
judgment.
So Jesus then equates himself with the
Almighty by not just healing diseases,
forgiving sins, and knowing people's
thoughts, but then he says, "The
father's given him all authority to
judge for condemnation." We know that
this is the context of judgment in focus
because of what Jesus said in verse 24.
Whoever hears his word and believes in
him who sent him has eternal life. that
individual what
does not come into judgment because
they've already passed from death to
life. In verse 25, Jesus said, "A time
is here already where the dead will hear
Christ's voice and those who hear will
live." That's not the physical
resurrection. That's the new birth.
Those that this has happened to, they've
already passed from death to life. He
then says, "An hour is coming when those
in the tomb will hear his voice and come
out, both the righteous and the
unrighteous. Those who have done good
are those who heard Jesus's word and
believed him who sent Christ, and they
have eternal life." Verse 24. But those
who are evil will come into judgment for
condemnation. Both parties will stand
before him on the great final day. But
those that believed the gospel and have
passed from death to life already, they
will not come into condemnation.
The reason Paul could say in Romans 8:1
that there is therefore now no
condemnation for those who are in Christ
Jesus. The key being in Christ Jesus is
because we were judged for condemnation
in the person of Christ at Calvary. His
cross was my cross. His death was my
death. He is my representative and who I
am seen as righteous in. When the wrath
of God was poured out on him, that was
him bearing the wrath I deserve. His
propitiatory sacrifice. But it doesn't
end there. His resurrection is my
resurrection. His acceptance before the
father is my acceptance before the
father. His ascension is my ascension
and confidence to enter the holy places
with confidence. All of that is because
a person is in Christ.
But in the investigative judgment, the
law can still condemn you.
But the Bible teaches that if the law
were able to condemn the believer that's
in union with Christ, it would have to
be able to condemn Christ. And it can't.
I already came into judgment for
condemnation because that's what Christ
bore for sinners and it wasn't able to
contain him.
I live because he lives and you do too.
if you're a born again Christian. All of
this flies in the face of the
investigative judgment. Now, he's going
to talk about their teaching on the
close of probation. Now, let's discuss
the close of probation.
Let's go in our Bibles to Daniel 12 and
verse 4. Daniel 12 and verse 4. Now,
this verse is not directly related to
what we're studying, but I'm reading it
for a specific purpose, and you're going
to see why. It says there in Daniel
12:4, "But you, Daniel, shut up the
words and seal the book."
Now, was the book going to be sealed
forever? No. Because it says seal the
book until when? Until the time of the
end. So, if the book is shut and sealed,
can people get a message from the book?
Can the people read the book and
understand the book? No, because it's
shut and it's sealed. So, if the book is
shut, a message cannot come from it.
Now, notice it says until the time of
the end. And then it it states, "Many
shall run to and fro and knowledge shall
increase." And that's been severely
misinterpreted because basically uh the
way that it is generally used is that
you know that when it says knowledge
shall be increased, it's talking about
airplanes and and uh missiles and
electric toothbrushes and and all of
this technology stuff. But that's not
what the text is saying. What the text
is saying is that the book in this case
it's a particular portion of the book of
Daniel is shut and sealed. In other
words, it cannot be understood. A
message cannot come from it until the
time of the end. But at the time of the
end, people are going to run to and fro
and knowledge of the book is going to
increase because the book will then be
what? The book will then be unsealed.
The book will be opened. We could would
it be too much to say that the secrets
will be unsealed?
No, let's
So this entire theory rests upon the
phrase the time of the end in Daniel
12:4. Christian, understand that
there's a special message that couldn't
be understood until the time of the end,
which is referring to the end of the
world. A secret message. And then Boore
giving a a little tongue-in-cheek play
there with the name of his organization,
which is Secrets Unsealed.
But fundamental to the SDA framework is
the idea that the end times started in
1844.
But that's not what time of the end is
referring to. Anyone can access sources
on Hebrew grammar and better assess what
is in focus. It's not the end of the
world. It's referring to the appointed
time which comes for the fulfillment of
the prophecy. The time and focus being
the time of the prophecy, not the time
of the end of the world.
It doesn't automatically mean that.
Notice now what 19th century Anglican
theologian Charles Elott explains in his
Daniel commentary just very succinctly
on the phrase shut up the words. He's
not unique in this. He just explains it
really nice. Quote, "The revelation
which commenced in Daniel 10:20 now
draws towards a close and the prophet
receives a further revelation respecting
the time of the end. The revelation
continues to be called by the same name,
the words, as in Daniel 10:1. And now
the prophet is told that the book in
which this revelation is written must be
placed in a safe and sure place
for the need of it will be felt in the
time of the end. That is in the time
when the fulfillment makes the meaning
of the prophecy clear and unambiguous.
Close quote.
the time when the prophecy is made clear
and unambiguous.
When the time of the prophecy ended, not
the end of the world.
The SDA pioneers read into this and then
they assume that their understanding is
in focus.
Since it says the time of the end, it
must be talking about the end of the
world, the end times.
When no,
it doesn't necessitate that. And that
foils this whole idea that the SDA
church has some special knowledge and
insight into prophecy that no one else
has and all these sort of other things
that flow down from this. Furthermore,
the biblical writers did not consider
the end times or last days to start in
1844. We were just in Hebrews earlier in
Hebrews 1, the author says that in times
of old, God spoke through the prophets,
but in these last days, he's spoken to
us by his son. Peter preaching in Acts
cites Joel who prophesied that in the
last days the spirit would be poured out
and charismatic you know gifting would
overflow. He doesn't cite this to refer
to a long off distant future but there
at Pentecost it was being fulfilled
there.
This is one of the many prophecies that
Peter's Peter goes through and mentions
with the purpose of stating that these
things that the Jews were aware of from
the Old Testament were being fulfilled
there in their midst. not simply
reiterating to them things they already
knew that were still long off into the
future. That makes no sense contextually
with what Peter was doing
to Revelation 22 and:es 10-2. Revelation
22 10-12. And what I want you to notice
is that there are three points of time
in these verses. Three points of time.
Revelation 22:es 10-12. You'll see why I
read that verse about the book being
sealed, about the book being shut. And
he said to me,
"Do not seal." That's the opposite,
isn't it? Do not seal the words of the
prophecy of this book. It's talking
about Revelation.
Now, what does that mean? Don't seal the
words of the prophecy of this book. Can
the book of Revelation be understood?
Can a message come forth from it? Can
people receive the message and be saved
by studying the book of Revelation? Yes.
Because it says here, don't shut up the
book. So if the book is open, a message
of salvation can come from it. That's
the first point of time. The book is
opened. Everybody can read it and
understand it and be saved. But now
comes the second point. It says, "For
the time is at hand."
In other words, the book is open now,
but there's a time, a certain event
that's going to take place at a certain
time. What is that event that is going
to take place? Let's read the rest of of
verse 10. For the time is at hand.
He who is unjust,
let him be unjust still. He who is
filthy, let him be filthy still. He who
is righteous, let him be righteous
still. He who is holy, let him be holy
still. Does this sound pretty uh uh
pretty determinative? Does does this
sound like all cases are decided?
Absolutely. In other words, when this
takes place, the book will no longer be
opened to present a message that will
bring salvation. The time has come for
where all cases have been decided. The
unjust will continue to be unjust. The
filthy will continue to be filthy. The
righteous will continue to be righteous.
And the holy will continue to be holy.
But there's a third point of time and
that's in verse 12. Notice it says there
in verse 12 and Jesus is speaking and
behold I am coming quickly and what and
my reward is with me to give to everyone
according to his work. That's the second
coming of Christ, isn't it? So do you
notice three points of time in these
verses? First of all, the book is open.
A message of salvation could come from
it. Oh, but the time is going to come
when all cases are what? Decided. And
then Jesus is going to what? He's going
to come and he's going to bring his
reward. So, does probation close before
Jesus comes to reward the saints?
Absolutely.
All right. So, he claimed the time is at
hand in Revelation 22 is referring to an
event that's going to happen at a
specific point in time.
This is why I constantly say that when
people like Ted Wilson claim that the
SDA church upholds the historical
grammatical method of interpretation,
it's only lip service. Makes me wonder.
It's like, do they even know what that
means?
Because the individuals that John was
writing to
that had zero significance.
Utilizing the HGM means one has to
understand how the original audience
would have understood the text and then
make modern-day application from there.
Bore did not do this.
His application of the text is entirely
denuted from that and then things are
anacronistically read into the text.
They're not in focus.
They come from the great controversy
worldview that not only the apostles
didn't have, including John, but the
original audience that John wrote the
revelation to.
It is conclusively true that they did
not understand this paricopy to be
referring to the investigative judgment
and salvation being rewarded based on
the outcome of that event. And when the
time comes, uh, probation has closed.
This is coming from the SDA church's
sanctuary model of salvation, which is a
part of the great controversy worldview
that the SDA church tells us they were
uniquely given. No one before them had
it. We have looked at a multiplicity of
sources on that numerous times. Remember
what we read in Hebrews 9 earlier
regarding it being appointed for men to
die once, then comes judgment, and why
the author includes that where he did.
Now, I like how succinctly Albert Barnes
explains this phrase, "The time is at
hand." Catch this.
Speaking on that phrase, he says, "That
is they are soon to commence." It is not
implied that they would be soon
completed. The idea is that as the
scenes of persecution were soon to open
upon the church, it was important that
the church should have access to these
prophecies of the final triumph of
religion to sustain it in its trials.
Compare the notes on Revelation 1:1 and
13.
So when one understands this, you can
understand how revelation applies to
both the original audience, the early
church as well as that same church
to this day, the same body of believers.
That is the what the apostles creed is
talking about when it says the communion
of saints. One body of people all
connected. Those that have gone before
us, ahead of us, those who are in heaven
right now. It's why when Adventists try
to tell you some will try and tell you,
"Well, we affirm, we can affirm the
Apostles Creed." No, you can't.
You don't believe you commune with the
church in heaven, for example, on the
Lord's day because you guys aren't there
on the Lord's day. But nevertheless,
this set of verses still applies to us
today. But it can't just be denuted from
the people John was writing to. The
overarching theme of the revelation is
that Jesus is the head of the church.
He's ruling and reigning and his kingdom
is growing and growing and growing and
it will triumph over all evil. Don't
fret. Don't fear.
Christian Jesus is alive. He's real,
guys.
He's real.
He's king of all kings, all earthly
powers. He's accomplished redemption.
The gospel is true. So don't lose sight
of this despite what you may see around
you. Obey the gospel. take it to the
nations boldly despite whatever it may
cost us.
What Boore puts forth here creates
conflict with other places in scripture
because like I said, it's almost as if
they they read revelation denuted from
the whole of the biblical narrative.
Adventist theology does hopscotch exesus
through the biblical text, citing proof
texts here and there. But when one does
that, it's easy to create
contradictions, which is often what
happens. This part of the revelation is
considered the epilogue
and it is describing the church's
triumph over evil in history. Something
Jesus himself said would happen.
We also saw that he will rule and reign
until when? All of his enemies are made
a foottool and he will return to throw
death, the last enemy, and the wicked,
the contents of Hades, into the lake of
fire. But Boore also talked about verse
11. Let him who is righteous be
righteous still. He who is holy, let him
be holy still. And he connected this to
the reward mentioned in verse 12 to try
and shoehorn in the SDA teaching of not
only the investigative judgment but also
sinless perfectionism which in their
system are intimately intertwined.
He said, 'It sounds like all the cases
in the investigative judgment have been
decided at this point, and Jesus is
coming with the reward for those who are
keeping the law perfectly and made it
through the pre-advent judgment because
that's how you make it through it. Which
means the book will no longer be open,
revelation, to present a message of
salvation, which then ties in their
doctrine of the close of probation.
The just will continue to be just and
the unjust, the unrighteous will
continue to be unrighteous.
What Ellen White referred to as a
lockedin character. When probation
closes, your character for eternity is
locked in. And if you didn't get to
having an identical one to Jesus,
achieving a return to being made in the
image of God, yours will be filthy and
will remain as such.
which demonstrates why this system robs
the scripture of its glory by throwing a
the a theological wet blanket on it and
smothering it out.
How is what Steven Boore presented
supposed to be encouragement to the
original audience John was writing to?
Think about this. Think about this. They
were about to undergo severe persecution
and needed to persevere under the
pressure and not give up the faith. And
John wants them to know that the seventh
day Adventists in the 19th century are
going to have a special present truth
end times gospel message that not even
the apostles preached which they will
allegedly take to the entire world as
God's last day people.
You know folks cuz because when you're
about to be crucified and lit on fire or
fed to the lions that's really what's
going to be of great encouragement to
you to persevere, right? That's what
Ignatius was what had on his mind when
he's being taken to to be fed to the
lions.
Again, notice what Barnes continues to
point out regarding verse 11
and the reference to the sealing of the
book.
Seal not the sayings of the prophecy of
this book on that phrase that is seal
not the book itself for it may be
regarded altogether as a prophetic book.
on the ceiling of a book. See the notes
on Revelation 5:1. Isaiah and Daniel
were commanded to seal up their
prophecies. Their prophecies related to
far distant times. And the idea of their
being commanded to seal them was that
they should make the record sure and
unchangeable.
That they should finish it and lay it up
for future ages so that in far distant
times, the events might be compared with
the prophecy. And it might be seen that
there was an exact correspondence
between the prophecy and the
fulfillment. Their prophecies would not
be immediately demanded for the use of
persecuted saints but would pertain to
future ages.
On the other hand, the event which John
had predicted, though in their ultimate
development, they were to extend to the
end of the world and even into eternity,
were about to begin to be fulfilled and
were to be of immediate use in consoling
a persecuted church.
John therefore was directed not to seal
up his predictions, not to lay them away
to be opened, as it were, in distant
ages, but to leave them open. so that a
persecuted church might have access to
them and might in times of persecution
and trial have the assurance that the
principles of their religion would
finally triumph.
See the notes on Revelation 10:2.
John isn't talking about the book of
Revelation being open for a time to give
a message of salvation that will be
unique to a 19th century group of people
who they and they alone have
that not even the apostles preached a
present truth message. And then once all
the cases are decided in the
investigative judgment and all
characters are examined to see who is
and isn't sinlessly perfect and safe to
save, Jesus will return with his reward
for their obedience.
John is following the same language and
pattern that other prophetic books
followed regarding it being sealed. And
the sealing had to do with signifying
application for future generations. Not
one single generation in the 19th
century but even the 9th, 10th, 11th,
etc. centuries.
It describes events that were about to
uh uh to be fulfilled
which were also used by John to console
a church which was about to face heavy
persecution. and it did and it applies
to the church in all ages to be reminded
and assured that Christ wins.
I want to reiterate, understanding this
allows you to make sense of the
immediate application and context of the
church in history as well as up to the
modern day versus reading a novel
concept and idea into the text that
would have been of zero comfort and even
understanding to the church in history
that it was written to.
with regards to him trying to tie the
righteous and the filthy to the
investigative judgment in the same
verse. Verse 11, notice what else Barnes
highlights
on the phrase that he that is unjust,
let him be unjust still.
This must refer to the scenes beyond the
judgment,
not the investigative judgment. Steven
Bore and the SDA church commit word
association fallacy here.
The word judgment doesn't automatically
mean investigative judgment.
This must refer to the scenes beyond the
judgment and must be intended to affirm
an important truth in regard to the
condition of people in the future state.
It cannot refer to the condition of
human beings on this side of the grave.
For there's no fixed and unchangeable
condition in this world.
At the close of this book and at the
close of the whole volume of revealed
truth, it was proper to declare,
remember this is the epilogue, in the
most solemn manner that when these
events were consummated, everything
would be fixed and unchanging, that all
who were then found to be righteous
would remain so forever, and that none
who were impenitent, impure, and wicked
would ever change their character or
condition.
that this is the meaning here seems to
me to be plain and the sentiment accords
with all that is said in the Bible of
the final condition of the righteous and
the wicked. Close quote.
The thing that is unfortunate about the
SDA view is that it is close to the
truth.
It subtly twists what John is signing
off with
because yes, he is talking about
judgment and Christ returning with a
reward. But they insert into that things
from the great controversy worldview
that this is the investigative judgment
when that isn't the judgment in focus.
Remember earlier from Hebrews, judgment
for condemnation. Believers have already
come into already passed from death to
life by virtue of being washed in
regeneration, transferred from the
kingdom of darkness into the kingdom of
light. They don't come into judgment for
condemnation. Yet the investigative
judgment is a judgment to determine
that.
Barnes points out that this is in
reference to after the great day of
judgment, though, not after the SDA
church's novel investigative judgment.
It can't be about humans on this side of
the grave because we're not in the fixed
unchangeable condition yet. Boore would
associate this with the close of
probation. As you heard, probation is
the time for you to get to a character
identical to that of Jesus's because
when it closes, it's locked in. Then the
time of trouble will come. So, it's
locked in before that. And that's what
he associates with the righteous will be
righteous, the unjust unjust. No, this
is talking about after the great day
when the consummation of all things has
happened
because notice what Ellen said.
Quote, "Now while our great high priest
is making the atonement for us, that's
the investigative judgment. We should
seek to become perfect in Christ."
Not even by a thought could our savior
be brought to yield to the power of
temptation. Satan finds in human hearts
some point where he can gain a foothold.
some sinful desire is cherished by means
of which his temptations assert their
power. But Christ declared of himself,
the prince of this world cometh and hath
nothing in me. John 14:30. Satan could
find nothing in the son of God that
would enable him to gain the victory. He
had kept his father's commandments, and
there was no sin in him that Satan could
use to his advantage. This is the
condition in which those must be found
who shall stand in the time of trouble.
Close quote.
So when probation closes, your character
is then locked in. This is the same
woman that said at the second coming,
nothing about your character will
change. Quote, we're not to settle down
expecting that a change of character
will come to us by some miraculous work
when Jesus shall appear in the clouds of
heaven with power and great glory. No,
my young friends, we are judgment bound
and probation is granted to us here in
this life.
Why? In order that we may form
characters for the future immortal life.
Close quote.
That is what Steven Boore was claiming
there. But no, Revelation 22:11 is after
glorification has taken place. A
doctrine that SDA theology does not
properly understand.
There's nothing in this text about Jesus
securing a second probation for you to
with his help develop an identical
character to his. And if you do, you'll
be rewarded with eternal life. You'll
vindicate God or you'll help vindicate
God against Satan and all this other
stuff.
Believers already have eternal life.
something many neoadventist types will
insist they also believe. Well, that's
not consistent with this system, my
friend. This is a big TBD right now
based on if you get to an identical
character Jesus was in before probation
closes and the time of trouble starts.
Otherwise, Satan will get you and you
won't make it. In the same vein, the
Review and Herald, December uh December
10, 1889.
Quote, "And Enoch walked with God, and
he was not, for God took him." Genesis
5:24. "It is only a short journey to the
heavenly hills, brethren, if we walk
with God." In John 15:10, Jesus tells us
he kept his father's commandments. He
did not say, "I am trying to keep them,"
but he says, "I have kept them." So, it
is not enough that we try to keep the
commandments. We must keep them. The
character of the saints is not
established by their failure to keep the
commands of God, but by their success in
doing so. Those who simply try to keep
the commandments are moral cripples.
They do not walk with God. They simply
hobble along after him. Close quote.
Very clear and forthright.
Do not let Adventists try and tell you
Christian that this movement simply
teaches Christian perfection like John
Wesley and Methodist believe. No, this
is another one of those superficial
appeals to try and legitimize their
view. Trying is not good enough.
This has not changed. This is
foundational to the great controversy
worldview. silencing Satan and God
vindicating his character, which is
precisely the title of Steven Boore's
series and what it all centers around.
The great cosmic controversy, how God
clears his name of false charges.
And that's part of how this supposedly
happens with Jesus's help getting to a
totally sinless condition, which
demonstrates that Satan is a liar and
that the law can be kept. This also
demonstrates that you're safe to save
and can be trusted in the new earth and
the new heavens to not let sin enter
again because remember no change of
character comes from glorification.
It's not nothing's going to change about
your character when Christ returns.
Those that get to this identical
condition as Jesus will be rewarded for
doing so with eternal life
as we have looked at numerous times.
Quotes on that. That's not how one
receives eternal life, my friend. It
might sound pious and noble, but it is a
deception that turns your eyes onto
yourself. Jesus is then your divine
cheerleader, and it's time for you to
get ready. Get ready. Get ready. Like
Ellen White's angel supposedly told her
in June of 1850.
Time is short and you have a lot of work
to do. So, get busy. Get busy. Get busy.
No. Jesus accomplished redemption in
full already.
And the real Jesus is a savior.
Not because you enable him to be one
because you come alongside him in a war
that he's allegedly in with one of his
creatures. He is a savior because he is
powerful, mighty, perfect, and able to
save to the uttermost because of his
indestructible life like we will see
next week. because of his forever
interceding on our behalf which does not
fail for any of those that he makes that
for. Eternal life is a gift, not a
reward. Ephesians 2, Jesus says in John
17 that eternal life is knowing the true
God, being united to him.
Obedience is not rewarded with eternal
life. You're not rewarded with knowing
God based on how well your obedience to
him goes.
Christians seek to obey God because we
are known by him. Galatians 4:9 and
already know him ourselves.
A desire to obey comes from that already
being a reality.
The wicked do not have that desire and
want. They're still spiritually dead.
But I am still frail, weak, and feeble.
I I'm not one of these, you know,
Adventists are holier than the rest of
us. That they don't sin. They're they're
commandment keepers. They're they're
perfect.
But I I'm not I I'm willing to recognize
that I am fail uh uh frail, weak, and
feeble. I still fall short of the glory
of God because sin is both nounal and
verbal, both an action and a condition.
I have good days and bad days. I war
with my flesh every day and long for the
day that it's glorified. The curse is
lifted off the creation and the
consummation of all things happens. and
that war is finally put to bed. It is at
that point that the actual application
of all of what Christ accomplished is
applied and then we will be sinlessly
perfect.
But Jesus is not frail, weak, and
feeble. He is faithful and he is saving
his people. And seventh adventism,
meaning the false system,
will one day be made a foottool for the
feet of Jesus to the praise of his
glory. his gospel, his church will
triumph and overcome.
So if you are an Adventist, it is time
to repent of your idolatry,
repent of your pride, humble yourself
underneath the word of God, and come to
know the truth. You need to heed Paul's
words in 2 Thessalonians 1 5-12.
After Paul begins by commending them for
keeping the faith amidst persecution, he
writes, "This is evidence of the
righteous judgment of God
that you may be considered worthy of the
kingdom of God,
for which you are also suffering.
Since indeed God considers it just to
repay with affliction those who afflict
you and to grant life to you who are
afflicted as well as to us when the Lord
Jesus is revealed from heaven with his
mighty angels in flaming fire inflicting
vengeance on those who do not know God
and on those who do not obey the gospel
of our Lord Jesus.
They will suffer the punishment of
eternal destruction away from the
presence of the Lord and from the glory
of his might when he comes on that day
to be glorified in his saints and to be
marveled at among all who have believed
because our testimony to you was
believed.
To this end we always pray for you that
our God may make you worthy of his
calling and may fulfill every resolve
for good and every work of faith by his
power. so that the name of our Lord
Jesus may be glorified in you and you in
him according to the grace of our God
and Lord Jesus Christ.
If you do not know the true God and obey
the true gospel,
not the Adventist God, not the Adventist
special present truth end times I keep
the Sabbath, I'm good to go gospel.
The coming judgment is not going to be
good for you, my friend, because it's
not the investigative judgment. That is
not what's coming. That's not what's
going on right now. It is the great day
of judgment. And Jesus is coming back to
pour out his wrath not on those who
didn't yield to the SDA church's novel
cursed gospel, but on those who didn't
obey the real one, which Paul says in 1
Thessalonians 1:10, the first time he
wrote to them. That is how you can be
considered worthy of the kingdom of God.
Actual good works can flow from this
first knowing the true God and the true
gospel.
That happens first
knowing the true God and the true gospel
that then results in the good works.
But you already know the true God. You
already have eternal life. Adventism
does not possess this. Cannot give that
to people.
So you can stay on that hamster wheel
and keep going and keep going and keep
striving and do all these things. Never
going to make it. It's not how you get
there. Like I said, next week we will
get into part two and pick up where we
left off and talk more about the close
of probation, Michael the Archangel, the
time of trouble, and the scapegoat. May
Christ richly bless you in the grace and
peace won by him and his vicarious death
on the cross for sinners. Hallelujah and
Marinatha.
[Music]